on en est à combien 10-11-12 de 12 13
mon dieu ce que j'ai de l'hypertension
s14 ça y est c'est la fête du slip ça ne
s'arrête pas qu'un génial 16 formidable
tout va bien
[Musique]
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui d'un
objet connecté très sérieux non pas que
les autres ne soient pas sérieux mais
celui là est très sérieux je vous
parlais dans une obscurité qui peut vous
sauver la vie
il est dans cette petite boîte là bien
évidemment je vous parle de tech mais je
veux aussi vous parler de teck par
rapport à la santé la e-santé sens où
jackie qui m'intéresse beaucoup et
toutes les problématiques de santé je
vois je vais pas vous raconter mes
histoires personnelles mais c'est un
truc qui m'intéresse et qui du coup un
vrai sens une vraie résonance pour moi
alors j'ai un objet lac qui peut vous
sauver la vie
il est là dedans il est caché dans cette
boîte quel est l'enjeu quel est le but
de ce produit je vous parlais d'une
maladie c'est ce qu'on appelle lâcheté
assez l'hypertension artérielle qui est
une pathologie qui touche énormément
monde et beaucoup parce qu'ils sont sous
diagnostiquée ou même si elles ne sont
contrôle pas forcément contrôle
relativement mal leur tension artérielle
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément les moyens parce que les
objets sont un peu gros un peu bruyant
vous pouvez le faire chez vous vous
faites pas tout le temps et c'est pas
toujours terrible terrible du coup j'ai
un produit qui est assez intéressante
qui je pense pour à solutionner la ville
ya pas mal de monde pour deux raisons
principales la première c'est parce que
c'est un produit qui est léger pratique
il emmène partout avec soi qui est très
discret et qui vous servira dans deux
cas principaux le premier c'est pour
effectivement suivi d'hypertension
artérielle suite à une pathologie de le
contrôler régulièrement pour savoir où
vous en êtes et le deuxième qui laisse
un peu sur de la médecine préventive
on parle d'un produit qui a été créé par
un brunch pas si vous connaissez omron
moi j'ai connu une ronde lorsque j'étais
responsable webmarketing dans une
formation lit parce que parle dans le
truc et aumône fabrique des produits qui
s'est effectivement entre autres à
mesurer votre tension artérielle et
celui aller franchement cool parce que
il est petit il est pratique ils seront
là dedans et franchement je pense que
peut vous sauver la vie voilà la boîte
voilà l'objet europe je loue revoilà
voyez c'est tout pratique c'est tout
mignon ça ça sert à mesurer votre
pression artérielle
laissez-moi vous montrer comment ça
marche c'est très facile vous le prenez
vous le positionner comme ça directement
à votre poignet une fois vous êtes là
vous venez directement la lune est élu à
vous indiquer si la position et bois de
la voyez je suis trop faut que je baise
faut que je le best of the best faut que
je
des jeunes baisse voyez ces aliments
bleus ça veut dire que mon bras est bien
positionnée up dans l'alignement par
rapport à mon coeur est là il va
commencer à mesurer donc là il commence
à mesurer tout doucement tout doucement
tout doucement
là j'ai un petit voyant hockey en bas ça
me dit que mon bras c'était bien
positionné ils repèrent mon rythme
cardiaque il mentir mentir mentir mentir
mon oncle il va commencer à céret
commence à mesurer on en est à combien
10-11-12 de 12 13
mon dieu ce que j'ai l'hypertension 13
14 ça y est c'est la fête du slip ça ne
s'arrête pas 15 génial 16 formidable
tout va bien 17 voilà donc là j'ai un
petit 15 9 pour vous dire je suis quand
même assez haut et en plus la voyez là
où il ya les deux petits coeurs ça veut
dire que j'avais des battements
irréguliers
pendant la mesure youpi tralala tout va
bien donc là typiquement les dans un cas
d'école et quelque chose près up voyez
qu est ce qui m'a dit il m'a dit que au
final d'un j'ai tendance à taper un
petit peu au parce que si je regarde ma
notice que vous avez là ça vous donne
qu'à son et les mesures moyenne de la
pression artérielle au cabinet d'un
médecin c'est toujours un peu plus
stressé donc si elle est supérieure à 14
9 si vous êtes un hypertension
artérielle et à domicile à 13,8 13,9 ça
veut dire vous êtes en hypertension
artérielle
donc là moi j'ai un résultat et 15,9
autant vous dire que je suis carrément
au alors je suis plus est en train de
faire la vidéo donc je suis un peu
survoltée ce qui peut expliquer cela
quand je le mesure est tout à l'heure
j'étais quand même plutôt cool et c'est
là où c'est très intéressant parce que
il se connecte directement à mon
application et ça permet effectivement
de voir l'historique de mes mesure j'ai
mon appli qui hélas omron connect je
clique et l'agent mais mesure donc là
j'ai la mesure qui vient d'être
synchronisées à l'instant mon famille
15,9 et j'ai également ma mesure de
pukki est là alors j'ai mon journal que
je peux faire par moi-même et voyez ce
qui coule c'est lorsque j'arrive là eh
bien voyez je vais pouvoir voir ce qu'il
en était est-ce qu'il a été aujourd'hui
et au final ça va me sortir une moyenne
du 24 mars au 30 mars jeu tournait
plutôt à 12,8
avec un rythme cardiaque de 78 des pme
parce que oui il faut quand même faire
gaffe
il faut mesurer sa pression artérielle
mais il faut pas la faire n'importe
comment suis je suis juge un peu dans la
course vous fait la vidéo donc
fatalement je vais être plus speed il
faut prendre sa tension artérielle
lorsque vous êtes posé vous reste une
bonne demi-heure après un effort vous
êtes tranquille vous est posée bien
alignées votre bracelet par rapport à
votre coeur coups de poser lui
vous indiquez en fait c'est ça qui est
vraiment très pratique c'est que on
n'est pas des professionnels de la santé
vous et moi donc vous avez besoin quand
même d'être assistés il va vous dire si
votre bracelet est bien positionnée
aussi il faut le boucher
si votre bracelet et à la bonne hauteur
par rapport à votre coeur pour qu ils
pas de billets pour que ça fonctionne
bien et ensuite il veut faire la mesure
vous pouvez la consulter et vous aurez
des résultats qui sont fiables
en plus ce qui est cool si vous pouvez
avoir pour deux personnes pour vous
votre compagne votre compagnon votre ami
ce que vous voulez donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant
s'il ya bien un truc qu'il faut pas
prendre à la légère quand on souffre
d'hypertension artérielle c'est bien de
se mesurer de ce contrôle est pour
vraiment savoir où vous en êtes donc ça
c'est franchement intéressant et cet
outil est vraiment très pratique
c'est pour ça que je content de pouvoir
vous en parler parce que je vous parle
beaucoup d'objets technologie je parle
beaucoup de smartphones de tablettes de
monde d'ordinateurs mais ça c'est un
objet connecté c'est un vrai sens donc
qui se connectent très facilement en
bluetooth directement à vos smartphones
il vous permet de mesurer votre pression
artérielle de connaître votre pout de
faire un suivi par personne d'avoir
votre profil et de sortir une moyenne de
pouvoir voir où vous en êtes et vous
pouvez même le montrez votre médecin
après lorsque vous allez consulter le
dire regardez voilà ce qu'il en était
vous allez pouvoir tenir également votre
propre journal enfin c'est vraiment un
outil qui est très très très pratique et
je pense qu il fondamentalement si vous
l'utilisez sérieusement peut vous sauver
la vie alors vous me dire il en existe
d'autres
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
mais celui-là il a quelques atouts qui
sont non négligeables le tout premier
c'est le fait qu'il est extrêmement
discret vous le prenez vous le mettez là
dedans vous l'emmener partout avec vous
vous glisser dans votre sac dans une
sacoche dans ce que vous voulez il est
vraiment très très très pratique
deuxième point et non des moindres c'est
qu'il est hyper silencieux si par
exemple vous travaillez vous êtes au
bureau vous allez vous mesurez vous
contrôlez vous voulez vous isoler et pas
que tout le monde sache que vous êtes en
train de contrôler votre tension on
n'entend absolument rien absolument rien
et là il est en train de bosser leur
classe une erreur parce que je les
placer n'importe comment mais voyez on
n'entend absolument rien et c'est
vraiment à mon avis un des atouts de ce
produit parce que si vous êtes coutumier
ou coutumières de la prise de tension
pour tenter toujours les appareils qui
gonfle qui vont pour ronronner et qui a
faim on dégonfle et ça ça fait
absolument aucun bruit c'est hyper
discret et contourner dans les vies de
tous les jours on n'a pas forcément
envie que vos collègues de travail vos
amis
n'importe qui dit savent que vous êtes
en train de vous contrôler et de mesurer
votre tension ça c'est quand même plutôt
cool et puis surtout le gros gros gros
point positif c'est qu'il est très
facile à utiliser
si vous avez une pathologie
d'hypertension artérielle ça c'est
plutôt cool c'est un produit qui
chaperonne il s'appelle le rs 7 et le
délit était à haïti
il est plutôt cool et coûte entre 80 et
100 euros si vous intéresse vous avez un
lien en bas dans la description
dites moi si ça vous botte alors je vous
parle un peu de santé connectés
aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un outil que
je trouve intéressant parce qu'en plus
il ya un vrai sens il connecter à votre
smartphone ça c'est trop cool
dites moi si ça vous botte que je vous
parle de produits de santé comme
celui-là il en existe plein il ya plein
de solutions et puis la santé connecter
ce quelque chose qui se développe
énormément qui va continuer à se
développer
déjà pour de la médecine un peu
traditionnelle pour nous soigner des
pathologies mais aussi pour de la
médecine préventive et je trouve ça
vraiment très intéressant que ça a un
sens de pouvoir se mesurer
soit vous souffrez d'une pathologie vous
allez vraiment de savoir où vous en êtes
soit vous commencé à entrer dans un âge
où il faut commencer à se contrôler et
auquel cas un outil comme ça je me sens
vraiment cool dites moi vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire est ce
que vous souffrez d'hypertension
artérielle ou vos proches
et est ce que vous trouvez qu'un outil
comme celui là un sens est ce que vous
trouvez ça pratique simple et au final
si vous souffrez d'hypertension
artérielle
si vous devez vous contrôler
régulièrement est-ce que cet outil-là
petit pratique silencieux peut vous
intéressez vous marquez tout ça en bas
en commentaire et dites moi si vous
voulez que je vous parle d'objets
connectés liés à la santé vous marquez
tout ça si ça vous botte on continuera
sinon on passera outre vous embrasse à
très bientôt tokyo
[Musique]